To motivate our discussion of scripts, let us continue with our metaphor of
machines with whom we can talk in stories. Now the Watson program and
the Siri program, normally they understand stories that are limited to
one sentence. You can ask Watson a question, you can ask Siri a question,
and those questions are one sentence questions. Similarly when Siri and
Watson reply, they typically give their answers in one word or one sentence at
most. The story plays a very important role in the life of quadrant division and
we would expect AI agents that live among quadrant divisions also to be able to
understand stories. And one of the common roles that story players that
they enable more common sense reasoning. To see how stories enable common
sense reasoning, consider two simple sentences. Imagine the first sentence was,
Ali asked, do you think we'll have many customers in the next half hour?
And the second sentence is, Sarah replied, go ahead and grab your lunch.
So these are two sentences of a story. Does this story make sense to you?